で 次はこの智慧完成する人の話なんです
あの三十九番目は で 三十九番目は智慧を完成した人の条件なんです
アナヴァッスッタ・チッタッサ・アナンバーハタ・チェータソ・プンニャーパーパ・パイーナッサ・ナッティ・ヤーガラトー・バヤン
アナヴァッスッタっていうのはこの漏れるという意味で
心に外からいろんなものを漏れて漏れて漏れて漏れてもう中に漏れてね
だからこの雨 屋根だったら漏れることよくないでしょ
雨漏り 雨漏りじゃ何て言いますか
雨漏りです 雨漏りすると困るでしょうに
家を作ったら窓からあれやもう悪臭やら音やら何でも入るわとかね
屋根から雨漏りするわとかね
床から水が上がってくるわとかね
もう最悪でしょう 中いる人には
それで心の中にも今は我々その最悪状態でいるんです
心に外からあらゆる汚れがもう割り込むというか
もう侵入するんです もうどうしてもまとめな人間でいられません
私は立派な清らかな心でいようかなと思っても
すぐもう侵入されちゃうんです
目を開けたら誰かが目に入っちゃう
それでも心がもう見ただけで揺らいで汚れてしまう
いろんな音が通る 音が入ったらもう心がもう汚れてしまう
その状態ではもう最悪なんです
それで智慧を完成した人がしっかりできた家のように
窓が閉めたら音も入らないし
もう屋根はしっかりしているし
もうドアも全部閉じちゃうと
もう完璧なきれいな状態でいられます
外から誰かが侵入しようと思ったっても
こちらはインターホンで見て
ああ 入れてもいい人か
ない人かと見てから はい
どうぞというか 結構ですというか
それだったら状況はすごく安全なんですね
そこで智慧完成した人はそうなってるんです
世の中でいろんな美しいものあるんですよ
見てはいるんですけど
心は汚れません 人が自分を褒め称えたっても聞こえます
理解もしています 何言ってるのかと
でも心は汚れません 私たちとは随分違う
ここで真面目に説法を聞いていても
外誰か何か言ったら見るでしょ
心が汚れているし 揺らいでいるし
首を回してそこを見ちゃうんですね
だから完成した人の心はそうじゃないんです
もう何も侵入しません
で どうしても入れなくちゃいけないデータだったら
どういうことかと調べて入れてあげる
いらないんだったらもうスイッチをオフにしておく
テレビカメラついてるなんてインターホンみたいなもんです
一応外の情報は一応アクセスディマンドする
だからピンポン鳴らしたらもう私の情報を入れてくださいってことでしょうね
で それだったら まあインターホンを外したらもう画面で映るでしょ？どんな人かと
そこで条件は何なのかと
まあこういうこと はい
結構ですと言うと 今それで遮断でしょ
入れてもいい人だったらまた入れてあげる
人間はそういう風に自己管理しなくちゃいけない
それは完成した人にできるんですが
普通の人にはできるものじゃないんです
だからそこでお釈迦様の道を歩んで
自己管理できるようにしなさいと
次の言葉はアナンバーハタ・チェータソ
で これブッダゴーサ長老の注釈もあって
またいろいろ意味が アナンバーハタっていうのはもう心がこのもう嫌な状態
イライラ状態 なんですね
嫌だ嫌だもうイライライライライラ状態状態は穴はないということで
このイライラする状態はない
イライラする状態というのは怒りなんですね
いろいろ情報が入ると
もうもうキリがない 何か考えるとイライラする
もう嫌だ こんなのは とかね
それは怒りですね だから
この怒りの状態からもう心はきれいになっている
外からこの侵入 情報が侵入して汚れません
情報は侵入しますけど
別にそれがあまり影響を与えない
それで人間というのはこの情報がなくてもイライラするんだから
怒る場合は別に情報があってもなくても怒るんです
情報がある時は情報があると怒って
ない時はないと怒る 何も情報ないのではないかと
だからそこはもう外と関係なくても怒れます
怒りの場合は 怖いのそういうわけなんですね
欲の場合は綺麗な人を見たんだから欲が出たんだと
また ものすごい醜い人が次に見たらね
あのもう消える可能性もありますし
で 怒りはそうじゃなくて
もうかなりこのもう質が悪くて
もうネバネバしてもう熱するんですね
怒りは 例えば欲の場合はすごいごちそうがあります
もう高価な食べ物を見ただけで食べたい食べたいと欲が出ている
その欲を消すことはすごい簡単です
自分の好物だと何と言っても
それで他の人が来て あの皿に何かちょっとゴミとかね
まあ生ゴミありますね
大根切って皮を剥いてぼんぼんとつけてるでしょうにね
まあ鶏ももうチキンの皮やらゴミちょっと持ってきて
あの上にちょっと置いて置いて
またきれいにまた出してる
それだけで全部食欲も食べたいなこれって全部消えるんです
別に不潔なわけじゃないんですよ
ゴミ箱にあっても大根の皮でしょうに
自分が食べるために持ってきたチキンの皮でしょ
あれも食べるでしょ 料理して
だからゴミ箱から取ったんだからといって
もう清潔じゃない 健康に悪いっていうのは
これはありえない 論理的には
どうせビニール袋でも新しいビニール袋を入れてゴミを入れてますからね
ありえない しかし 人間はそうじゃないんです
で 例えば焼き鳥があって
焼き鳥がすごい好きで
もうもう丸焼けで そこでもうちょっと飾りしましょうと言って
ゴミ箱から大根の皮を剥いた
大根の皮を持ってきて
綺麗に焼き鳥 丸焼きの鳥を飾っておいちゃうと
もう食べないんですね
見たんだから  [背景音楽]だから欲っていうのはそんな不思議なもので
もう食べたくてしょうがなくていたなのに
瞬時にもう嫌 私には 食べないと
と思う だから欲はそんなもんですよ
いい加減な欲なんです
もう論理的じゃない 怒りはそうじゃないんですよ
例えばそれ見ちゃうと欲がなくなって怒りが出てくる
せっかく食べたかったのに
なんてことこのバカがするんでしょうかとかね
欲の代わりにその人に対して怒りが生まれるんです
それがいくら頑張っても消えません 「
そんなこと気にすんなよ
あいつはふざけて遊んだだけではないか」と 「
ふざけて遊ぶのはいいんだけど
あんなことやるもんでしょうか」と
そんな怒るんです 「いえいえ
あいつはわざわざとあなたにあなた食べるんだからやったことだからいいんじゃないんですか
あなたそんなこと食べたって体に悪いし」言っても「だから怒ってる」と 「
食べようと思うと私が食べようと思ったんだから邪魔したんではないか」と言って怒るんです
だから一旦怒ったら それどうやって消すかわからないんです
欲が出たらもう何とかして消せますよ
怒りはできないんです
難しい 自分好き気に入ってる相手がいる
もう自分がものすごく夢中になっていて
欲があって そこで友達があの人はいろんな友達作って遊んでますけどね
あなたに隠れてとかで言っただけでも
何とかちょっと減るんですね
気持ちが またまた二 三回言っちゃうと
やっぱり付き合いはやめてしまうんです
欲はそうじゃないんです
欲じゃなくて怒りはなかなか質が悪くて消えない
現れちゃうとずっと怒りが続くんです
そこでアナンワーハタっていうのはそうやって怒りの思考で内の中を壊すんですよ
内面的に精神を破壊する過程
一回欲は内面を汚す過程
あらゆる情報を侵入して侵入して
心が汚れて汚れて汚れて汚れてゴミ箱になるんです
怒りは逆に中でもう侵食して侵食して内面を破壊していくんです
そこで自分の服を入れてる何か箱とかありますね
服なんか置いておく その服を入れてる箱に動物を飼うと
まあ箱の中だから大きな動物は飼えません
猫とかね リスかネズミだったら飼えます
それでネズミを飼って
自分の服も入れていて
そこで引き出しの中にネズミの住んでもらう
ネズミにはいる場所があって
餌をそこであげるとネズミはどうしますかというと
この引き出しの中にいて全部噛むんです
あの服を 噛んで噛んで噛んで
それ終わったら引き出しそのものを噛み始めるんです
これはネズミのやり方
リスを飼っておけば リスはそんなに服を噛もうとはしないんです
リスはもし子供が産もうとなんとかしようと思っちゃうと
外へ出てあっちこっちゴミを持ってきて入れるんです
自分の服を入れてる引き出しの中に
どこかからよく髪 髪の毛
紙やらね もういろんなものを持ってくるんです
持ってきて砕いて砕いて砕いて中で巣を作るんです
そこで子供を産むと どちらでも中は最悪状態
引き出しはもう服は入れている入れる入れる状態じゃないんです
どっちにしても服は使えなくなっちゃうんです
だからネズミ飼っちゃうと中を破壊する
それは怒りですね リスを飼うと外からゴミを持ってきて入れるんです
それは欲の例えになるんですね
日本でできるんだけど
大体リスなんかはね 自分の子だといっぱいいますけど
もう家でもうそこで放し飼いにしちゃうと
外よりは家の中安全だから
家の中にいたいんですね
リスも いるのはいいんだけど
いろんなゴミを持ってくる
持ってきていろんな上
いろんなところで巣を作っちゃう
だからゴミだらけになるんです
逆にネズミは飼うことしませんだけど
入るともう全部噛む 噛んで破壊する
それで心もそういう状態なんです
そこで智慧完成した人の場合は
この問題 2つもないんです
外から侵入されて心は汚れることもないし
心の中で怒りが回転して自己破壊になることもないんです
アナンワーハとチェータソーというのは自分で自己破壊的な心もないんだと
プンニャパーパパヒーナッセ
次の言葉 プンニャパーパパヒーナ
プンニャっていうのは徳
パーパっていうのは罪
善悪ですね 善悪状態を捨てているんです
いわゆる心はすごい綺麗なんです
できてない人は善行為をして悪行為をやめなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは不完全な人の生き方なんです
どうせ心は汚いんだから
悪いことをしないようにと頑張らなくちゃいけない
汚いんだから 心はできるだけいいことをして
いいことをして 心を綺麗にしなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 智慧を完成したら
心は無色透明で 善も悪もどちらにも影響を受けない
それは超越した状態になるんです
それで悟りの境地は善でも悪でもない境地なんです
その人に最後の言葉 ナッティジャーガラトウバヤン
ジャーガタっていうのは徹夜するというね
寝ないでいるという意味なんですけど
いわゆる何て言いますか
寝られない 不眠症ですね
これ単純です 不眠症って言えば
なんで人が不眠症になるんですかね
あんまりにも心が問題いっぱいあって
もう落ち着いた綺麗な状態じゃないんです
誰でも何か心配する問題が入っちゃうと
もう寝られないんですよ
で 寝られなくなっちゃうとさらに心配するんです
あ 大変だ 寝られないんだとかね
そうするとさらに頭の状態が悪くなるんです
どうせ元々落ち着いてないんだから寝られない
それから 寝られないことでさらに落ち着きがなくなる
走り回ったりする という意味でもあります
心は完全で悩むことはないし
汚れないし 汚れが侵入しないし
中でも怒りもないし 善悪というふうに悩むことはね
はない 善悪で悩むということは
あの人は悪人だ あの人はいい人やとか思っちゃうと心がすごく揺らぐんですよ
悪い人だと思った人は嫌になるわ
いい人やと思った人の方に心がもう傾くわ
人を区別判断するわ それはあんまり良くないんですね
激しい道徳感で 激しい善悪感で生きることはとってもきついんです
決していい人間になりません
この道徳感 道徳の何ものでしたっけね
なんかもう これが悪い
これが悪い あれが悪い
こんなことやってはいけませんというふうに
もうやってはいけないことばっかり喋ってる人々っていうのは
もう精神的に落ち着けてないんですね
人が悪いことしたって別にそれ気にしないとか
いいことしたってもだからっていうのはあまりもない
そういういくらかのこの冷静なクールな状態じゃないと
心広い人間にはなりません
狭い人間っていうのは激しい激しい善悪は
だから人はすぐ捨てる
悪人扱いする それはものすごい嫌な性格になるんですね
智慧が完成したらそういうことはなくなっちゃうって
すごく大らかになるんですね
だから人が悪いことしたっても
まあ気持ちはわかるし
で これは悪いことだよと言うんであって
お前は悪い人間やという態度は取らない
人がいいことをするんだったら
あんたやったことはすごくいいことだよと言うんであって
したがってあなたは良い人間やというふうに判断して困るということもしないという
清らかな状態にはなります
だからその人にとっては夜寝られなくても別に問題はない
智慧が完成した人は大体が寝ないんです
寝る必要ないんです ずいぶん心を落ち着かせて統一して喜んでいるんです
大体それぐらいの意味だと思いますが
またもう一つ意味がありますよ
寝られないということはどういうことか
起きているんだっていうことなんですね
私たちはこの生きてるっていうことはどういうことかとわかってないんです
寝ているんです 生きることは大変な苦しいことであると全然わかってないんです
で 友達がいること 家族がいること
好きなものあることは
ものすごい足かせで罪の大元やとわかってないんです
生きることというのはものすごい恐ろしいんだと
罪ばっかり起こすんだと
これキリがなく苦しむんだよと
全然わかってない だから寝ているんですね
寝ていて ああ なんて幸せだ
なんて幸せだと しかしたまたま目が覚めるんです
目が覚めた瞬間 すごく自己嫌悪に陥っちゃうんですよ
なんで私はこんなことをやらなくちゃいけないかと
どこまでこんなことやるのかと
例えば 子育てに必死で喜んでやってる母親も
時々なんで私はここまでやらなくちゃいけないんですか？とかね
いくらやっても なんでこの連中は言うことを聞かないんですかと
わがまま放題で生きてるのに
なんで私はもう奴隷みたいにね
もう旦那の面倒見て 子供の面倒見なくちゃいけないかというふうに
やっぱり嫌なこと 嫌なこっちゃとなる
なる時もあります それでわざとそれごまかしちゃって
また夢の中で喜ぶんです
だからたまたま目覚めるんですよ
人生に 目覚めた時の画像は全然良くないんです
すごく嫌な気持ちになるんです
自殺したくなるんです
なんでこんなことやらなくちゃいけないかと
何やってるんですかと
だから実際の生きるっていうことは
とんでもない 恐ろしい
とんでもない 無意味な
とんでもないこの嫌なことなんです
それで私たちは永遠睡眠状態で永眠状態で
もう夢ばっかり見て なんて素晴らしい人生ですかとか言いながら
友達に裏切っても そんな一人二人に裏切ったっても
世の中でいくらでもいい友達はいるんだと
相手に裏切ったら そんな一人二人に裏切られたってても
信頼できる人間はいくらでも世の中でいるんだぞとかも
わけのわからないことを言いながら夢を続くんです
[背景音楽]ですから
この私たちはこの夢を続けるために
芸術いろいろ開発するんです
科学も開発するんです
よかったよかったと そういういろんなごまかしを作って
その中に隠れて時間を何て言いますか
壊すんです  CD 1枚でも買ってきたら
そこでちょうど 1時間ぐらい何もしないで夢の中でいられるでしょ
映画 1本で見たら 2時間ぐらい
自分の人生を無駄にすることはできます
それで 死ぬまでいかに時間を無駄にするかということがなければ生きていられないんです
いわゆる事実に目覚めないようにする
例えば 映画っていうのは明らかにそういうことでしょう
実際の世界にあることがまるっきりありえないように
ありえない世界を作って
我々に見せる一つもありえないもの
例えば 映画で立派な英雄を見せても
そんな人間は一人もいません
道徳観念も また正義の味方で微かにも悪いことをしない警察官とかなんとかとか
それで瞬時に犯人を捕まってとかね
ありえないんですよ そういう映画を作るアメリカでも
殺人と全くも関係ない人々は死刑にするんです
その被害も被告人にはもう金はないんだから
弁護士立てることもできないし
また法律でも立てられないとかね
でお金がある人はものすごいお金かけて弁護士を立てて
犯人であることはもう裁判官も知ってるし
もう陪審の人々も知ってるんだけど
認否に抑えられちゃって無罪にする
それからまた悪口 やっぱりやったのはあいつやと
もう 2回目裁判できません
そこで堂々と自由 捕まらなかったら時効ないんだからさ
殺人には 一生ちょっと怖くて生活しなくちゃいけないんです
それで捕まったならば
もうお金かけちゃえばもう自由になるんです
そうすると堂々と それから言ってもいいんです
どうだい？私はもうやったんですけど
もう証拠揃わなかったんだから
言ってももうどうできません
そういう まあそういうことで
で 私たちはこの映画で
実際の世界はそういう嫌な世界なんですよ
私は一番言いたかったことって一番ではなくて
すごく言いたがっていることがありまして
この 法律は平等であるという言葉があるでしょう
日本で知らないんですけど
ヨーロッパでは裁判に使う紋章も目をなんとか神女神のそうでしょ
目を布で隠しておいてはかりを持ってるんですね
だから もう何の固定概念もなく正しく判断するんだという意味なんです
人間平等 あの人王様だ
この人は奴隷だということは目があると見えるでしょうに
そうすると王様の方に判断が傾く可能性ありますから
見ていないんです ただ重さだけでは嘘です
あんなのは 法律こそ不平等なんです
それは権力ある人に 金がある人に
上手に嘘をつける人にはもうすぐ勝てるようになっています
何の出来ない人だったら
ものすごいもう他人の罪まで自分にもかぶされるんですよ
それはもう本でいくら書いても
やってるのは人間だからね
日本の警察の人だって
もう誰か捕まって その人にそこら辺全部罪をかぶせて出した方が自分たちが仕事したことになるんです
だから これはもう 例えば国会でいろいろ法律作るでしょ
どんな法律作ったって
もう議員さんたちだけには徹底的に甘いでしょうね
一般国民にはえらい厳しい
なんかどこに平等ですかと
世界はそんなもんです
だから我々は映画で夢作るんです
すごい立派な人間 いて
事実から目をそらすんです
事実見るともう嫌でたまらないんです
自分の子供を見るとだらしなくて
わがままで もうできれば捨てたいんですけど
捨てられないんだから育てるんですよ
しかし 映画の家族の見てください
もう可愛くて可愛くてもう真面目でもう我慢見ていられない
もう楽しくて それが夢です
そういうことで 私たちはこの事実見えないようにと文学
芸術 無駄話 あらゆることをして作って
電車に乗ってじーっと立っていることをね
座っていること つまらないんですよ
すぐ気づいちゃったらちゃうと
もう通勤には 3時間かかるんだから
私の 1日はどれぐらいもう 1
時間半行って それから 1時間半そこでもう寝る時間まで縮むでしょ
で 駅までまた 30分かかるとかね
そんなことを考えちゃうと嫌だからね
寝るか本を読むか漫画を読むか
で 漫画をじっと読んでいると
いい気分 なんて幸せかと
自分がマイホーム作って
結構東京から離れたところで幸せやと思っちゃうんです
あの 3時間はもう計算に入れないんです
そういうことで 人間誰でもこの夢の中で人生ごまかしてきてるんです
だから目覚めたら困る
一般の人は人生に目覚めちゃうとみんな自殺しようと思います
それぐらい苦しいんです
生きることは それで智慧を完成した人は目覚めることには全然気にしないんです
それ怖くないんです 智慧を完成しているんだから
我々は目覚めちゃうとかなり怖がるんです
だから生きることはドッカである苦しみであるという
たったその言葉だから
仏教には人気ないんです
汝らは神様に創造されている神様の子どもやという
もう完璧な嘘を言っているところでは
もうかなり人気あるんです
どうか神の恵みがありますようにと叫んで
もう喉から血が出るまでお祈りするんです
見ていられないんで あのバカバカ神が目が耳が遠いんですかね
あれほど叫んでも なんで恵みを与えてくれないんですかね
あいつはケチか耳が遠いか
人の話がわからないか
もうどちらかですか いくら祈っても世界は苦しいでしょうし
貧困はどんどんひどくなるでしょうし
戦争は絶えないでしょうし
で 神を信じる人はまるっきり信仰しない人よりすっごい悪いことをするし
神をまるっきり信じてない人々も真面目にいるんです
なんだこの世界はと わからないんですけどね
そんなことをしたら だからブッダが目覚めた言葉を言ったんだから
仏教は嫌いだと 別に嫌いでも結構ですけど
どうせ元々無知だから
でもそんなことで我々はやっぱり事実は知れなくなっちゃうんですね
だから普通の人の場合は
事実に目覚めることっていうのはかなり怖い
例えば結婚して仲良くしているでしょう
旦那がただ単に自分のために自分をつかまって結婚して家に置いているんだとわかったら気持ちいいんですかね
ただ単に便利な道具として料理作ってくれる
お風呂入れてくれるわとかね
結局はそれにやられて奥さんの面倒見るんですよ
事実はそれだけなんです
でも女性の方々は私のことを愛しているんだとかね
愛しても心配も全然してないと思いますけど
だって他のもっと可愛い女の子とちょっと喋りかけたらそちらに行くんだから
それだけのもろいんですよ
この愛情っていうのは
それで旦那に期待できない場合は子供にかかっていくんですね
子供を育てる そうすると子供から見れば鬼じゃないかと
これといういっそ逃げていこう
すっいつか早く逃げて
そちらは子供たちが それわかったらどうなるんですかね
お母ちゃんって言って甘えたってもね
これ自分で何もできないんだからなんです
あれ食べたい これ食べたい
お母ちゃん 今度ハンバーグ作ってくれとかね
それでお母さんは喜んで作ってあげたりするでしょう
それでおいしそうに食べるとすごい気分が良くて
皿ぐらい洗わないでしょうに
そのまま外出ていくんですね
で バカな母親もそれやらせない
喜んで食べたんだからよかったね
今日はとかね 私は料理作ったんだから
お前ら皿洗いなさいって言う
だったら平等な世界で楽しいんですけど
そうするとすごくうまくいくんですけど
それはしない で とにかくお母さんとして
子供たちはいくら甘えていたっても
そいつらの狙いは一人立ちできた瞬間で出っていくことではないかと
その時は母を忘れるんではないかと
それでまた何か問題が起きたらまた来るんではないかとと思っちゃうと
こんなにやる気がなくなっちゃいますよ
旦那もそれでこちらもこれでとわかっちゃうと
だからやっぱり夢の方がありがたいんです
夢の方がありがたいと
ただ生きてるだけなんで
それでも結果は ロボットとしてプログラムされてる
プログラムをこなして死ぬ
それはもう仏教は全部もう解除して新しい世界を作ろうと
自由な世界をね だから智慧完成した人はそういうどんないかなる束縛からも解放されて自由にいる
その人は目が覚めてるんです
寝てないんです でも恐怖感何もないんです
ということで この目覚める
寝てない状態っていうのはすっごい意味深い
簡単に解決 解説できない言葉なんです
ジャーガラタっていうのは言葉が
ジャーガラタっていうのは辞書を引けばもう徹夜する意味なんです
徹夜しても怖くないんだぞというと
どういう意味かというと
こういう意味なんです
徹夜するっていうことは目覚めているっていうか
寝てないって意味なんです
寝てないということは
ものは見えてるんだっていうことですね
何を見えてるかというと
人生見えてるんだっていうことなんです
人生見えちゃうとえらく怖くなるんです
もう自殺したくなるんです
それは智慧を完成していない愚か
無知な人々の世界なんです
それでお釈迦様は智慧を完成しなさいと言うんです
智慧を完成したら目覚めているんです
目覚めている人は人生を知っているんです
知っても怖くないんです
なぜかというと この普通の生き方を乗り越えているんだからなんです
ということで 随分簡単な偈二つなんで
それで意味を終わります
私はもう一時間は喋る内容ないんではないかなと心配していましたけど